i you know i got to be honest with you
it is the most it seems like an
odd pairing to me that's what i was just
going to say it's the most bizarre
pairing jd and john heim
yeah like could john hein really be like
that engrossed in conversation with jd i
mean jd can't even get a thought out
when we're talking uh you know when i'm
not on the air i can i can conversate a
little better
oh yeah no you've been dating again
yeah why do you try to make up a big
word to just say talk
well i i thought conversate was a word
it's not a word if it's not the way
you're using it
oh i'm a great conversator i don't want
to start trouble but uh chris wilding
was telling me
he thinks jd is arrogant off the air put
it this way when i say hello to jd in
the morning back when we were at the
office i'd go hey jd how's it going i'd
get this
i get that that's not really that
that's how he says good morning that's
like selling an animal that's feral that
stops running i mean
you know that's jd like i go it's like
i'm the boss you know like
and i walked by jd every morning when we
used to have an office
and i'd go hey jd what's happening
i have trouble like saying good morning
i
i cannot like i don't know why it's a
weird thing
i say how would you ever function on a
regular job i mean uh i put up with any
of your [ __ ] i think it's fun
you know the more [ __ ] the better
yeah the more yeah like i'm like i got a
gold mine here
i would figure out a way to adapt uh and
i've
adapted how you would well
what you do here adapting oh yeah
unfortunately
what goes through your head when i say
good morning to you
there's two go-to's i go to it's either
grunting or whatever
or i'll go hey like richard christie uh
what is this
one just brunting or just like yeah
[Music]
people feel good jd thank you has anyone
ever considered that jd's never had a
good morning
yes well i'll tell you what happens if i
have to go
down the hall to ask jd to do something
i'll show up at his door and he turns
around
rolls his eyes oh listen that's not all
the time
arrogance what that's not
all the time sometimes i'll do that with
robin i'm like
joking around and then she'll just like
the way she reacts i
immediately i'm like oh god what did you
just do what are you doing
uh and so then i you know like battling
him on
hating myself even more the rest of the
day i think it's arrogance
yeah you do think it's arrogance oh wow
like oh here she comes again
because of the eye roll well i have
exciting news on our phone right now
conversating is jd and john hein
oh god hi guys many people take fast
food ice for granted
but not this cool customer john hines
best
fast food ice number one mcdonald's
it is wider than most others number two
raising canes and raising cane has some
tasty little cubes
number three chick-fil-a and it's ice is
yet another reason why chick-fil-a is so
beloved
number four mcdonald's
there they go they're the guys
conversating that's what it says
that is very accurate actually
i felt like i was there john john just
allowed to smart talking and i just
laughed